VIKINGS
AT THE CLEVELAND BROWNS. GO
BACK TO KANSAS CITY TO START
THE SEASON, JOE WOODS THE
DEFENSIVE COORDINATOR,
RECENTLY SPOKE WITH REPORTERS
AND AND
HE TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT,
YOU KNOW, THE OFFENSE IS
GREAT, BUT ON THE DEFENSIVE
SIDE OF THE BALL THEY REALLY
DID END UP
PAYING PAIR OF
FIRST-ROUND, PICKS IN GREG
NEWSOME AND
JEREMIAH
OWUSU QUORUM. OH, HERE'S WOODS
TALKING ABOUT THAT.
TO ME, IT FELT LIKE WE GOT
TO FIRST ROUNDERS FOR SURE.
AND THEN WITH GREG
BOTH, YOU KNOW, GREG ANGIE
OKAY.
THOSE GUYS ARE VERY SMART
PLAYERS, THERE ARE VERY
COMPETITIVE
PLAYERS, THEY JUST BRING A
DIFFERENT ELEMENT TO THE TEAM.
I MEAN, IT'D COME OUT THERE
AND THEY JUST GO W**** ALL THE
TIME.
THEY'RE TRYING TO LEARN AS
MUCH FOOTBALL AS THEY CAN.
THE VERSATILITY WERE
PLAYING WITH MULTIPLE POSITION
TO SEE WHAT THEY'RE CAPABLE OF
DOING.
SO IT'S BEEN GOOD HAVING BOTH
OF THOSE GUYS
INVOLVED.
YEAH, AND YOU CONSIDER THE
FACT THAT HAVE THE NUMBER ONE
OVERALL PICK FROM
2017. IN MILES GARRETT, THEY
GOT THE
OVERALL, PICK FROM
TWENTY, THIRTEEN OR
FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
AND JADEVEON CLOWNEY,
THEY GOT SOME SOME GUYS
WITH SIGNIFICANT PEDIGREE ON
THAT SIDE OF THE FOOTBALL. AND
WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
NOT LONG AGO, THE BROWNS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL
POTENTIALLY ELITE IN A
LEAGUE, WHERE
THERE AREN'T A LOT OF TEAMS
THAT HAVE
TRUE BALANCE AT A HIGH LEVEL.
THEY'VE GOT A HIGH LEVEL
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE BALL
AND NOW YOU ADD IN A
FIRST
ROUNDER AND GREG.
NEWSOM, AND A GUY WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN COULD HAVE
BEEN SHOULD HAVE BEEN A FIRST
ROUNDER IN JEREMIAH. SO
JEREMIAH WAS WHO QUORUM. OH I
GOT THE BRONZE ACTUALLY
THOUGHT ABOUT TAKING INSTEAD
OF NEWSOME, THEY GET BOTH
OF THEM.
IF IT I KNOW.
YEAH WE I MEAN MAYBE WE SHOULD
HAVE HAD THE BROWNS. MAYBE WE
SHOULD HAVE HAD THEIR BROWNS
IN THE NO EXCUSES DRAFT THE
OTHER DAY, BECAUSE THERE
REALLY ARE NO
EXCUSES. REMEMBER I WAS GONNA
PICK THEM, RIGHT? BUT YOU HAD
PICKED AN ORGANIZATION RIGHT
BEFORE AND I KIND OF JUST
CHECK IT OUT. BUT YEAH I MEAN
LOOK AT THIS GUY FIRST OFF
HEAT-SEEKING MISSILE LIKE WHEN
I SAY
GIVE
ZERO FS ABOUT HIS BODY OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHERE
IT'S GOING TO CHANGE THEIR
FOOTBALL TEAM AROUND. THE
THING THEY NEEDED WAS
SPEED AT THE
LEVEL AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS A LOT MIKE, YOU KNOW, IT
THAT'S SEATTLE SCHEME
TO MAKE IT WORK, YOU NEED
ATHLETIC
FAST LINEBACKERS. THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THAT. THIS GUY
IS AS FAST AS
CRAIG NEWSOME THE CORNER OR
YOU KNOW,
SAFETY'S IN FOOTBALL YOU KNOW
REALLY IT'S AMAZING THAT YOU
KNOW YOU'RE SAYING A RIGHT THE
ROSTER IS
IT'S ALMOST PERFECT. THERE IS
NO EXCUSES. I MEAN I KNOW IT'S
NOT PERFECT BUT IT'S DAMN
GOOD.
THERE'S NO REALLY
WEAK AREA ON THE FOOTBALL TEAM
AND
LET ME
FOR MY MONEY.
YOU COULD SWITCH AROUND. I
THINK
I'LL WOO SUK. OR RAMONA SHOULD
HAVE GONE TO PICK 26 AND
AND GREG NEWSOME HAD
PICKED 52 EITHER WAY NEWSOME'S
OF INCREDIBLE FIT
FOR THEIR SCHEME, YOU KNOW
HE'S
LONG RANGE E, RICHARD SHERMAN
TYPE OF BODY
AND REALLY PLAYING STYLE
TO ME
THAT FITS THAT SEATTLE
SCHEME AS WELL. HE'S NOT GOING
TO BE TO ME LIKE THE GREATEST
MAN-TO-MAN ISLAND
LOCKED DOWN CORNER, BUT HE'S
GOT INCREDIBLE
BALL SKILLS. HE'S GOT LENGTH
AND HE'S GOT A HE KNOWS HOW TO
PLAY THE GAME. HE'S
HE'S GONNA KNOW HOW TO PLAY.
HIS OWN AND READ COVERAGES IN
THE
COMBINATION. SO, HOW COULD JOE
WOODS? NOT BE EXCITED ABOUT
HIS DEFENSE AND WHAT THEY DID
ATTITUDE, JADEVEON CLOWNEY.
AND SOME OF THE OTHER GUYS
THEY'VE GOTTEN LIKE,
WOW, JOHN YOU KNOW, JOHN
JOHNSON FROM THE RAMS. I MEAN,
IT'S REALLY PHENOMENAL THE
ROSTER RIGHT
RIGHT NOW.
NOT A LOT OF QUESTIONS AROUND
THIS TEAM DURING THE BREAK
BETWEEN
OFFSEASON WORKOUTS AND THE
START OF TRAINING, CAMP BAKER,
MAYFIELD'S AGENT, RECENTLY
SAID THAT WE
THERE'S A BELIEF THAT MAYFIELD
WILL HAVE HIS CONTRACT AT SOME
POINT THIS SUMMER. I STILL
THINK THAT
MAYFIELD ALAN WAITING
FOR LAMAR JACKSON
BECAUSE THE ONE THING YOU
DON'T WANT TO DO IS PROVIDE
THE TEMPLATE FOR JACKSON
THAT THEN GETS USED BY JACKSON
HIS MOTHER AND WHOEVER ELSE IS
ADVISING THE PROCESS AS THE
FLOOR
FOR JACKSON'S DEAL. MAKE
JACKSON DO
HIS AND THEN YOU DO YOURS.
I THINK THAT'S THE WAY IT'S
GOING TO FALL. I THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE JACKSON
MAYFIELD ALAN. LET ME ASK YOU
THIS AND YEAH WITH WITH
NO GUARANTEE THAT ALAN'S GOING
TO GET HIS
THIS SUMMER, ALTHOUGH I THINK
HE SHOULD. YEAH, I THINK YOU
SHOULD DO IT. LET ME ASK YOU
THIS IF YOU'RE THEM RIGHT.
AND I THINK WE HIT ON THIS.
WHEN WE BROUGHT THIS UP A
LITTLE WHILE AGO,
BUT ARE YOU SCARED? IF
YOU'RE
MAYFIELD AND ALAN
BECAUSE OF MAYBE LACK OF
REPRESENTATION
FOR LAMAR JACKSON THAT
IF THEY GO FIRST, THEY MIGHT
TAKE A CONTRACT THAT'S A
LITTLE
LOW.
AND NOW YOU
YOU KNOW, HAVE LESS TO STAND
ON, WOULD YOU WORRY ABOUT THAT
ASPECT? IF YOU'RE IN THERE
THOSE
TWO SO YOU KNOW CAMP,
I DON'T WANT YA IF
JACKSON GOES FIRST AND HIS
DEAL IS BAD,
IT'S AN EASY
RESPONSE BY MAYFIELD OR
ALLEN'S AGENT. YEAH. IT'S AN
ABERRATION. YEAH, HE DIDN'T
HAVE AN AGENT, IGNORE
THAT WE'VE GOT, WE'LL, WE'LL
DO OUR DEAL. WHAT? WE'LL USE
THE DAK PRESCOTT
DEAL AS OUR TEMPLATE. HE HAD
AN AGENT, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
USE THE
DEAL THAT LAMAR JACKSON
DID, BECAUSE HE DIDN'T,
HAVE AN AGENT BUT I DON'T
THINK YOU WANT TO GO BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK YOU WANT TO GO.
I MEAN, YOU WANT TO GO AFTER
HIM. YOU DON'T WANT TO GO
BEFORE HIM BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S EASIER TO GET THE
BEST POSSIBLE DEAL AND NOT
LOOK BAD IN COMPARISON TO THE
GUY WHO DIDN'T HAVE AN AGENT.
IF YOU GO FIRST
AND HE GOES AFTER
THAT SETS THE STAGE FOR IT,
POSSIBLY BEING UGLY. SO I
WATCH FOR JACKSON'S DEAL TO BE
DONE, I WOULD SAY MAYBE EVEN
BEFORE THE FOURTH OF JULY, IT
COULD BE DONE BY THEN, WHO
KNOWS. BUT I THINK MAYFIELD
WILL BE AFTER THAT AND IF NOT,
BUT ALL THREE GUYS ARE UNDER
CONTRACT FOR TWO MORE YEARS
AND YOU KNOW, MAYBE ONE OF
THESE TEAMS
IS JUST GOING TO DECIDE.
TO LET IT RIDE. GET ONE MORE
YEAR OF PROOF BEFORE YOU MAKE
THAT LONG-